this is Edmund Tran here standing in for
writer Jenny Wu to give you her review
of monster hunter world for the full
thing be sure to check out the texture
version on GameSpot calm
[Music]
the seasoned players the gameplay loop
in Monster Hunter wealth is immediately
recognizable your job is a cycle that
involves crafting weapons bulking up
killing monsters and looting them for
materials however a well-crafted
narrative has not traditionally been
part of that gameplay loop and that may
have been a detriment for those looking
for a foothold into the franchise in the
past luckily for them
the first major point of difference here
from previous mainline titles is the way
that plot and gameplay are grafted
together
[Music]
while you spend a lot of your time
chasing an elder dragon that would it
look out of place in the movie Pacific
Rim once the hunter walzer's choice to
integrate guild and village quests into
one coherent story cuts out any
confusion or ambiguity that new players
may feel when it comes to figuring out
how to progress your journey the fact
that everything is tuned for a solo
experience is a plus it's entirely
possible to jump through 60 plus hours
of quests without ever interacting with
another player online on top of the
story which revolves around the mystery
of why the aforementioned elder dragon
has appeared in the game's new region
there have been some quality of life
changes that ease your transition into
the wall that wants to hunting instead
of front-loading a lot of text-based
tutorials as in previous titles you now
have a handler that doles out helpful
information to you as you progress
through zones of increasing complexity
the supplies you need to capture a
monster or on site make absolutely sure
you have tranq bombs
that one's a must it can feel a little
bit like having an annoying younger
sibling but her vocal cues and vast
knowledge about monster types are
helpful when encountering new enemies
for the first time her help stops when
you start cutting your teeth on high
rank monsters but hearing about new
skills and immediately putting them into
practice in the field is an excellent
way to learn about the game from the
ground up now once our world was always
promised as an open wolf experience to
some extent it delivers on that
fantastically large amounts of a scale
that we haven't seen before both
vertically and horizontally no
discernable game pausing loading screens
between zones and hunting areas and a
wealth of beautifully rendered
environments to slaughter colossal
monsters in
[Music]
out of the ability to slaughter said
monsters is the smart use of all the
tools in your hunting arsenal with the
most important being your weapon of
choice the hunter arts from Monster
Hunter generations have been removed and
the game's focus is solely on your
ability to dish out ridiculous amounts
of damage
using your respective weapons combo
light weapons are still the most mobile
while the technical weapons are still
the most difficult to understand and
master but there are ample opportunities
to get experience with whatever blade
bow or Lance you've decided on you'll
also make use of environmental hazards
traps barrel bombs and dung in order to
chase down your quarry there are many
different ways to get a leg up on
monsters which make encounters more
accessible to different playstyles
aerial mounting and elemental effects
are still all the rage with weapons
boasting essential new perks that
evolved alongside the enemies that
you've forged them from but the game
will reward you no matter what
strategies you take
multi-plane integration is for the most
part seamless as mentioned before
there's no distinction between village
and guild quests anymore submissions can
be done alone or with a friend and
you'll both only have to do it once to
complete it you can start a quest alone
in an online session and wait for some
mates to pop in to assist alternatively
you can seek out an online session for
people of a certain hunter rank and just
go along for the ride if they need a
hand with anything the difficulty will
scale depending on the amount of people
and the only qualifier is that some
story focused missions require the
leader to either watch a cutscene or
discover a monster before others can
join getting together with your mates
does take a few extra steps compared to
loading into a session with a stranger
if you know you've got a friend online
you'll have to join in on their fun via
the friends list on your consoles
dashboard while you can drop in and out
of public sessions with strangers easily
getting people to specifically join your
online session requires them to enter a
12-digit session ID in a game that's all
about momentum and sprinting off into
the horizon at the next challenge
getting your Posse together is
manageable but slightly tedious that
being said spending a few minutes to set
up a multiplayer session doesn't
necessarily make or break the game
there's also the ability to be in the
same online session as someone else
without actually having to do the quests
that they're doing which is useful for
those who might want to keep an eye on a
friend who's new to the franchise
players who are also struggling solo can
send out an SOS flare that lets others
put together a little rescue party to
save the day
now while it may seem that quite a bit
has changed there's also a hell of a lot
in monster underworld that has stayed
the same whether it's the appearance of
familiar monsters or the tried and true
weapons the roots of the Monster Hunter
franchise are strong with its latest
release apart from the overall sprucing
up of the graphics and the cutscenes
with full voiceovers the standout
improvements really come from the
simplification of existing systems in a
way that welcomes newcomers without
alienating existing fans a lack of
loading screens makes exploration of
pleasure and tracking new and improved
monsters through errors as they rank up
means that you've got plenty to conquer
once the story quests are complete there
may not be any new weapons and there may
be a hunter art sized hole left in the
hearts of players who spent hours
getting good at the various styles
however the removal of these old
mechanics feels less like a funeral and
more like a necessary streamlining
[Music]
ever since the title was first announced
last year it was clear that Capcom was
gunning for something grander than
Monster Hunter generations it has
succeeded and this is likely the biggest
and best that the franchise has ever
been it's not just the competitive depth
of the narrative it also boasts almost
seamless integration between combat
systems that were previously
incomprehensible for amateurs the
Monster Hunter formula has definitely
heard its claws and all the
aforementioned factors play their part
in making monster onto world a
meaningful evolution for the series at
large
[Music]
[Music]